li mortacci vostri che mi chiedete di
fare sti cazzo di horror questo gioco
può contenere dei bug guarda non è
quello che mi preoccupa se tranquillo e
pure la cinematica ci mancava solo quel
vabbè dai dell'addio di ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video che sono
fa vj non sono per niente preoccupato di
giocare a questa roba mi vedete che sono
bello tranquillo posso muovermi tornò a
c'è la torcia per terra la prendo ma
facciamola intero come si deve che la
partenza non è delle migliori che mi
sono svegliato quadro bellissimo chissà
volto il cazzo sono rimasto addormentato
che eletto ha preso la mia forma cioè
geniale vabbè lasciamo bellissimo il
muro ti siamo su race r e 77 si chiama
così sto gioco più non è bello e secondo
me il gioco ancora più bello guardate
che coincidenza
tornando di qua perché di là c'era un
orsacchiotto per terra gli orsacchiotti
mi fa cadere addosso quindi lo della
cosa stupenda che sto notando subito e
chi si muove tipo film cioè dei
movimenti lentissimi credo che sia una
roba tipo pt hanno iniziato a fare tipo
i giochi simili apt come 6 pt fosse un
gioco bello posso tornare nella stanza
di prima mi piaceva di più che sono fa
vj sono vengo in pace tranquillo posso
calciare questo pallone qualcuno lo
riprende posso farvi una domanda molto
semplice se fuori
c'è la luce non posso uscire con diceva
lui è chiusa il portato i nomi spunti
nessuno davanti poi sono contento a me
sono qua cazzo ma dovrà proprio come pt
se ti fa continuare a fare tutti i giri
di volta in volta fantastico che abbiamo
pagato la bolletta dell'enel in questo
istante perfetto riguarda l'importante è
che voi che usciamo poi non è che mi
interessa tanto qui il bello che tengono
la carta per non sporcare la casa e poi
la cosa fa cagare
c'è questo problema di fondo come sai
che la palla cambia sempre colore va beh
non importano avanti l'importante che
usciamo princess principesse
non posso entrare nella stanza della
principessa va bene importante che non
mi salti addosso satana poi sono
qualsiasi altra cosa va bene a quante
quotata la luce che adesso si spegne a
caso non era la luce invece era la porta
fantastiche aki sono importanti da vi
prego non fatemi girare vi prego perché
mi devo girare in questo preciso momento
e non lo voglio fare il a [ __ ]
non c'è niente meno male perché era un
cliché degli horror in teoria ci doveva
essere qualcosa ma vabbè se la parte
piano e facciamo uno contro uno io sto
importa chi questa importa
[Musica]
per chi parte devono guardare le gare
cecchetto estero quale bruttissimo
ricarica veloce veloce la prima che si
apra non si apre un cazzo fantastico
senti palla di satana puoi farmi
cortesia milano puoi smettere mi dà
fastidio ragazzi mi sta prendendo
leggermente male sta cosa possiamo
uscire per favore perché diventato tutto
buio ragazzi ragazzi
oddio questo è successo no vabbè negli
horror il verde no mi ricorda outlast
sta roba per cortesia così perché si è
spenta la luce con cosa sto guardando
dio esiste
grazie va bene va bene sentite che
potreste non spegnere una donna che
brutta cosa potreste non spegnermi la
luce per i prossimi dieci minuti almeno
che mi riprendo per cortesia si è aperta
ecco che è un'altra stanza questo no
vabbè no ragazzi vi prego a noi quella
di prima solo che più illuminato che
aveva niente va bene perché questa amp
giamo questa non è radio maria a fratte
proprio bene insieme voi due guardi in
un video ma sapete qual è la cosa più
importante che non me ne frega un cazzo
di chi siete cosa fate o di quando vi
sposate quindi fatemi uscire niente
continuando a fare avanti e indietro
quanto amo questo gioco bellissimo
proprio meraviglioso e sangue il sangue
questo fantastico non lo guarda e non
interessa neanche entrare là dentro
come va a finire così un gioco legge ma
[ __ ]
l'accordo ragazzi siamo su continuously
che sarebbe sempre ispirato apt anche
questo meraviglioso e o se riesco a
farmi incazzare anche questi special
thanks
sì sì numericamente life rate ma il
cazzo stanislav true colors chi va bene
mi interessa molto che hai fatto tu
gioco sia meno so come la maniglia forma
di pene lungo orte gigantesche rispetto
a me oppure sono io che sono un nano da
giardino non lo so permesso e se si
ripete tutto il percorso come credo che
andrà a succedere almeno sappiamo che
quello al piano 1 fashion week presse
che mia madre che mi deve venire a dire
che dove i compiti quasi che la
pressione questa porta deve essere
tenuta chiusa va bene ci ha scritto
almeno cerchiamo di capire una
precisione o al piano 1 ma come
fisicamente possibile questa va be che
anche prima non è che una pressione li
faccio mamma li faccio e lo programmi
finire il gameplay e li faccio non si sa
neanche se famiglia tre travi ci sono
voluti la palla c'era anche prima e non
si apre e va bene adesso che facciamo
torno indietro no ragazzino dai dai sei
sempre aperta porca eva perché io lo so
già cosa succede perché io sto facendo
questa cosa [ __ ] solo forte
però pensavo peggio
meno questa si chiude fantastico c'è una
torcia cosa me ne faccio si vede tutto
il piano era al secondo quindi questo io
sono faccio i compiti da ragazzi dai 9
che cazzo questo rumore prego grazie dio
bene non guardo
non c'e niente non c'e niente veloce
veloce non c'era niente che culo che
culo pensavo mi santa si imbocca
qualcuno non c'era niente fantastico
sembrava un teletubbies è uscito male ti
prego fatelo smettere
e orribile è orribile lo iodio puoi
smetterla per fare di cazzo sono ste
lampade che continua a esserci un gatto
che mi sta dando fa tutto tranquillo è
frate fammi una cortesia già che ci sei
puoi far smettere è sfogato inutile
[ __ ] sesta porta in di handel da
se rev.ma i just put into the ok ma
basta che finisce il gioco di gioco
amate un idraulico chiamato il cazzo che
volete
non me ne frega niente se avete un'idea
di di arredamento che fa veramente pena
ragazzi cosa sia bene lui è qui dove
dove dove cosa di cosa stai parlando da
un'ora e mezzo spiega mi capita mai la
porta
lo sapevo io sapevo che mi sarebbe
uscito dal muro prima o poi la pace dei
sensi che gioco di merda
quanta gente c'è voluta per fare
stanislao truxtun kamsky ti vengo a
cercare sappilo va bè ragazzi spero che
ai video vi sia piaciuto concludo che
l'episodio è stato alquanto strano prega
solis spero che viene sempre stato
lasciato un bel like che la pagina di
facebook e condivida tale descrizione
pesaresi di scatti di civiltà un
prossimo vip e ragazzi
[Musica]